toward the end of the class she wrote me
this long letter about like hey my
husband is a banker he's like runs one
of the banks if you want an intern when
you graduate let me know um you know I
think you have potential this and that
for business math numbers all this stuff
wow and then I joined the gang but like
during that time did you think about it
at all though when you first got that
letter like 15 seconds ago I was very
inspired
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the careful boys where today we have
Mr subin here sub what's up Subs what's
going on anybody call you Subs cool with
me Subs all right I got a question for
you first okay think of the best teacher
you've ever had what did they teach and
what made them so special Oh I thought
you said t-shirt that's what I said
that's what I thought too I was like
t-shirt this was nice teacher I [__]
apologize guys speaking of t-shirt you
guys could get this baby doesn't speak
with an accent you're her teacher hey
hey speaking of t-shirt you guys notice
the careful boys t-shirts you can get it
first week of
October Link in the description box oh
dude that's so sick can I buy one no
full price Co 10% on I'll take it I'll
give you one 10% off just you know all
right teacher teacher teacher H think of
the best teacher you ever had and
anything anything what did they teach
you what made them special someone that
made an impact in your life play
sentimental music in the background
Ryan's playing right now he's
[Music]
composing you're supposed to answer dude
we got caught up with the song it's so
good come back around come back
around no you know what stunt
coordinator you're stun coordinator
teacher stun coordinator three three
guys there's three
guys Justin U Kyle PA Andrew Franklin
those guys were Killers first big job
what made it awesome was they they
before the biggest gig has to happen
they'll come come to me like personally
and just talk to me like make me feel
very comfortable don't trip
relax make sure you flip over this way
that way you don't get hurt and then
blah blah blah blah they would keep just
they' be really good at explaining
step-by-step process of every situation
to the point
where that little edginess is relax and
then by the time it's time to shoot it
boom you send it and you're good to go
and they come back they you know they
look at you from the corner and just go
boom once that dumbs up you're like okay
super motivated and you're ready to do
it again and just the whole process not
even just doing the movies but how to
act around in the
industry don't be doing this so you
don't look stupid D D D D D those were
the best teachers actually one of the
highlighted ones so out of those three
you can only choose one pick one subie
they're all
watching Jak is very
famous come back around I'm back
around oh yeah floor's open floor's open
guys you have any teachers that you're
like oh I remember you I would say my my
dad was my teacher in a way cleaning
rocks yeah yeah for sure there's those
like those moments but um my dad taught
my brother and I Chess at a young age so
the way that he taught us chess too um
like we would have chess homework on on
different openings and mid games and end
game strategy um but I like the critical
thinking aspect that he taught us in
guards to chess um and the one thing
that always sticks with me is when you
see a good move look for a better one so
that's something I always applied to
life it's tight so yeah I would say him
what does that mean in chess so if your
opponent shows a good move then you so
like when maybe you see a good move on
your end yeah and you go okay yeah that
looks like a good move that would put me
in a more leverag position we'll look
for a better one meaning like look at
the whole board again because maybe
there's something you're missing wow
that's pretty cool cuz you Tunnel Vision
on that one thing so then it's like for
me I apply that to like all aspects of
my life and think about like okay maybe
not
react immediately to a certain situation
and look for a better move or a better
way of approaching it that would
probably put me in a better position
long term and I don't always do that but
I try to but you know you're supposed to
but I'm supposed to yeah but it's always
there it's always in the Forefront of my
mind so so I would be dope my teacher I
have one but I don't think I fully
understood what they told me until
literally this week SI [__] so I had a
teacher Mar ke shout outs to uh Mrs C I
don't even know if she's alive anymore
but she was like one of the most
impactful teachers I've ever had she's a
math teacher and um she always had this
thing where like she had the highest AP
pass rating in the nation like always
top 10 she taught the calculus and for
her everything started with belief so
starting from first day of class she
would stand just by the door and she
everybody come in give high five and say
I'm a committed to get a five on the AP
so everyone you every go everyone high
fives and walks in the class and then on
the way out high five and then her like
AP passing is always like 90% and above
and then 85% everyone gets the perfect
score in her class
and then so like like I understand that
concept of like believing in yourself
and if you don't believe and you doubt
yourself already then there's no way you
can achieve it right so I think I
understand that generic
concept and this week I was on a phone
call with like a business mentor and his
and his business partner and he said
something that I was like oh [__] I
never [__] saw things in this way and
he said this project that he's working
on he wants it to be like a feather in
his cap meaning like he wants it to be
when he looks in the rear view mirror he
wants this to be part of his legacy and
I've never looked at starting businesses
or anything in life from the exit point
of view you know when you get into
something you're like oh I want to do
Jiu-Jitsu M honeymoon phas whatever
right so like you're just kind of like
wandering around aimlessly where does
this take me oh this coach tells me to
do this whatever but when you've done
things so much you know every single
thing in the world has a a start and an
end so for him he looks at things from a
rearview Mir like he hasn't even started
yet but he knows how he wants to end it
and he knows he wants it to be a legacy
thing and I'm like oh that's the
difference between like people that take
every single brand deal that comes get
caught up in YouTube drama get gets
caught up in algorithm cuz they don't
know what the end game is so they're
just kind of like wandering around
versus people like GSP or whatever
they're like I want to be the greatest
of all time so that's it that means me
I'm only going to get sponsored by Nike
I'm only going to do this so they have
like a rock hard foundation and nothing
else can sway them so when he said that
I was like oh [__] but in order to think
like that you got to First believe in
yourself but believe in yourself in the
end product so instead of going like
well but the algorithm made me do this
it's like think about what your outcome
where you want that to be and then
reverse engineer your whole career and
like after I had that phone call with
him I was like dude I think that's what
Miss Cura meant like
believe in yourself but not just in the
beginning but begin uh believe in what
you want the outcome to be wow yeah I
should I got a quote for that man really
good don't just be rock hard have a rock
hard
Foundation nice that's also good thought
that was going to go somewhere else but
I'm glad it
didn't definitely throwing
off don't walk around with a boner there
it is flip it up in your waistband be a
gentleman right that's that's to fall up
all right don't walk around with a boner
all right so have a mission for your
boner about 30 seconds ago I was super
inspired have a
mission have a place to put that thing
yeah that's that's yeah that's also why
it's good to continue to have ment in
your life you know no for real cuz this
cuz these guys I was talking to they're
like 50 or 60 so they're like way ahead
and when you talk to them they're just
like oh [__] it brings so much more like
insight into what's going on it's
helpful and we get to get his mentors
you know talks we his knowledge if they
decide to call me once every 5
years you're not always bugging him like
Hey cuz I'm sure how do you even get a
mentor anyway like what do you do I I'm
straight up I'll just ask you have
mentors yeah I'll just be like hey can
can I text you and be like your annoying
brother and then a lot of them are like
yeah sure CU they like they like passing
that stuff yeah for sure for sure yeah
so many people don't ask it's it's that
it's it's basic like hey do you mind
like meet up for like just want to ask a
couple questions blah blah blah blah and
like you just start and the second you
like you realize that you have something
to learn you just ask again you ask
again three [__] coffee dates down
the line you're like oh this is kind of
like my mentor yeah you know what I mean
it just starts like that I told people
no
yeah was there a reason why again about
15 seconds ago I was
inspired I said [__] from what you know
right now do this this and this like
read this book probably take this and I
told I give him a route and I go then
probably but at this moment I don't
think it's good for either of us to have
this like the the questions aren't set
up correctly because you don't even know
anything so I'm not going to bring you
from the very bottom to the certain
point you know what I mean it's like
have a foundation that's like if I met
Elon Musk right now it's like it'll be
an entertaining time having a
conversation but when it comes to
business I'm not at his level to ask the
right questions to utilize that
relationship yeah in the best way you
have to be a certain level of a student
to even acquire that type of Mentor
that's true I think that's true cuz I
don't think I'd be of a good help if cuz
I don't think I explain things well in
um that phase like I think there's great
mentors for like a certain phase like
sometimes like from white belt to like I
don't know like purple or whatever right
you probably have a good maybe a kids
instructor someone in the beginner
instructor they're really good at that
stage and then maybe different stages I
don't think I'm actually a very good
coach at anything because I don't
explain things very well but I think I
bounce ideas back with people um that
understand already I see and they can
help figure it out for themselves and
some people when they say Mentor they're
actually looking for a babysitter which
is different that's what I'm talking
about the the I'm not here to inspire I
don't want to motivate and I can see
that in certain people and I'm like you
just want me to be your coach that's
motivating you saying you can do it and
I'm like I don't want that stage I want
someone that's like here's the three
things that I'm looking for can you like
what do you think here's my two options
what do you think so it's like a
Consulting Mentor somebody who does the
work isn't asking you to do the work for
them yeah that's if someone's like hey I
want to start business what should I do
and I'm like okay all right you go
Google um and then you go type in how to
start business and then there's a
thousand [__] articles on how to do
it don't ask me that you know yeah if I
feel like it's a rule of thumb if you're
asking me a question that you can easily
find out yourself don't ask it's already
an now dude yeah yeah well now these
days yeah [__] yeah there's so many
resources all over Instagram yeah well
just open up your Instagram there it is
everyone's Instagram looks different
though but the the scary thing is
everybody on Instagram is also like a
teacher and it's like wait a minute not
everybody's a teacher or just just right
now like during lunch I was talking to a
friend of mine who just published an
Amazon book and he goes hey I'm
interested in starting to do
merchandising now can you teach me and
I'm like yeah sure cuz it's a different
kind of conversation yeah it's
completely different from
like uh I think about I think I just
want to make my own business where do I
start like that's a different question
way too General yeah it's a very very
different question so like um yeah but
going back to the topic I I hearing your
story I realized like I was like damn
who is that impactful teacher and I
think for most of my life I had such a
bad relationship with with me in
education so like it's already like from
every class I went to I'm like oh
they're not going to like me cuz it's
like maybe I was disruptive in class I
didn't understand how to be a good
student so majority of the teachers I've
had I don't think they like me and I
don't think I enjoyed school but there
would be moments and one of them was at
keple where I always failed my math
classes and this was my um I think it
was pre-algebra algebra whatever it was
I I forgot her name man she was a
Chinese teacher older lady and she was
notoriously known to being a really mean
[__] so I wasn't going to do the work
I've already heard this rumor everyone
was afraid of her so I would be hella
rebellious I don't even know what
happened but I just started doing the
work I started doing homework I started
passing and toward the end of the class
she wrote me this long ass letter about
like hey my husband is is a banker he's
like runs one of the banks if you want
an intern when you graduate let me know
um you know I think you have potential
this and that for business math numbers
all this stuff wow and then I joined the
gang but like during that time did you
think about it at all though when you
first got that letter after like 15
seconds ago I was very
inspired that's the prom for this Joe is
an emotional roller coaster guys but I
was at it was a stupid time in my life
right but I think just reading it was
the first time I was like oh [__] like
really you really think that I can work
at this bank and then you think I have
potential and and you're going to
recommend me a job a big deal he's going
to Mentor me like I was like [__] and
I'm like but that's that's whack though
I don't yeah like working at a bank like
you go into a bank and Sh Square I was
like I don't want to I have to wear a
suit like I want I don't want a job
where I have to wear a suit but now I'm
like [__] dude imagine the the
mentorship the opportunity like all the
stuff that I would have learned if I
went that route yeah what's crazy is it
does it just start with someone just
believing in you for real that's all it
really starts and then you start like
having like it takes time sometimes you
still join a gang and you have to do all
these other things to get out of your
system but but he always goes back to
that belief of like damn someone did
believe in me at one point yeah that's
crazy that's a big thing too uh I think
for me one I could think of and I've
talked about him too but is uh Joe our
Jiu-Jitsu coach at the gym Joe tooro
yeah and uh when he came to the
gym it was that fight Academy at the
time we were all like Fighters and [__]
and we were all like oh we're Strikers
we're not like we just do Jiu-Jitsu for
fun we're not like really into it
whatever when he came along he he was
able to teach and distill information
down in a way where we were like oh [__]
we just looked at it so differently you
know U and that helped us kind of get
into it a little bit more and also too
like he's just um just such a good coach
and he has so much passion when he
teaches you that it's almost contagious
you can't help but the feel like oh what
the [__] I want to learn more about this
and that belief part too is like he kind
of pulled us to the side and spent a lot
of time with us out of like the rest of
the guys not like he wasn't coaching
anybody else but there was like a few
guys like some of the coaches at the now
at lionhart um like the main dudes in
the main group like you would spend tons
of time with us and he that whole idea
of he believed in us to be able to Excel
and at the time we were like yeah we're
not even [__] good at this like
whatever we're just [__] around like
that was kind of the attitude um but
yeah with over time then we started to
realize like oh [__] this is we have
something special here um and the way he
teaches the way he teaches beginners to
intermed mediates to advance people was
uh changes how we looked at coaching and
changed a lot for all of us so I think
he would be a good example of like of a
really good teacher that changed how we
looked at all of it you know it's crazy
how like great teachers will inspire
people to be students or better students
oh 100% that could be like defining
factor of either somebody starting or
never starting at all and then it
becomes a thing of like I need to make
this do proud he's put so much time and
effort into us that we need to make sure
this is not for nothing like we have to
make something out of this and you know
everywhere we went we were just we just
followed them and bro like for being a
teacher if you think about it well if
you were like in LA USD or something
right your your classes are jam-packed
with like 30 plus students you have also
kids that probably don't come from the
best home situations so they're
disruptive they're Knuckleheads you have
to be a good babysit
and you have to be a good Mentor and you
have to control the class and be Stern
and you also have to be entertaining
because everyone's add as [__] and they
won't pay attention to you but all the
at the same time you have to also care
to the point where they feel like
emotional connection where they feel
like listen to and all that it's so much
like they should just be able to go in
there give instruction people receive
instruction and then like do it right
but there's so much more that they have
to do I'm just like bro that's a lot
yeah that's that's so much and I I think
like man I tormented the [__] out of my
teachers but did you guys ever have like
those teachers at your school that were
beloved by like the staff the kids and
it was all for those reasons cuz they
could wear every single [__] hat not
because not because they're necessarily
like the most special teachers in the
world but like they either have done it
long enough to understand that like oh
if I want to make my life easier I have
to have all those complimentary skills
of being being entertaining being fun
being patient and being able to like uh
deal with the kids that are difficult
you know so I think that in is a skill
of itself and I think some teachers are
just like not about that life they're
just there just because H whatever but
but yeah but those teachers that are
able to transcend all those things and
everyone is like I love this [__]
teacher you got to get this class like
those [__] change lives do you
remember that one teacher at keple she
was the political science teacher I
don't remember [__] she's so she was
awesome and another teacher named coach
Baldwin they're [__] awesome oh
Baldwin was cool cuz I remember like so
when we went to when we lived in the sgv
it was like crazy gang era right like
there's drive-bys in front of the
schoolz like there's fights all the time
it's like a crazy gang era and those two
teachers were the ones that really
didn't even give a [__] if you were in
their class if you just showed up in her
class so just let you sit there and hang
yes I had a teacher like that too they
knew that if not in this class probably
get shot so like I'll be like I forgot
her name but I'll be like yo I brought
four homies in this time and then she'd
be like okay that's fine and we just all
just sit in the back and that's even
better than us hopping the fence Mexican
lady the old lady miss coas m coas yeah
I had her for um Health
Miss she we she was so sick was awesome
cuz like if you just don't want to go to
your class cuz you just have people you
don't get along with or whatever you
just went to hers and she would just be
teaching or telling a story or like
you'll watch a movie or whatever and
safe Zone let people play cars in the
corner just do whatever as long as
you're in here safe it was cool that's
crazy same teacher at my high school was
just a cool all-around teacher people
would ditch their classes to go to his
class and he'd just be chill enough to
be like all right well I la her here
yeah yeah yeah cuz what we would do is
just hop the fence and leave get in more
trouble right hell yeah
that's good solution for that teacher
though but I do think it wasn't like one
person for me now I'm having all these
memories of moments from
teachers of like giving me praise or
helping me with self-confidence or
whatever and like I remember I saw how
many credits I had and I'm like there's
no way I'm going to graduate I'm a super
super duper senior so I said when can I
sign myself out and they said like 16 or
17 so all my my birthday I signed myself
out I went to continuation school I went
into continuation school and then the
teacher there he's like gave me an
assessment test spoke to me and he goes
what are you doing here like after a
month and I'm like what do you mean he
goes just take the GED and I'm like
doesn't isn't that like worse than a
diploma and I'm like shouldn't I work
through the diploma here and he goes it
doesn't matter whether it's the chps GED
[__] actual diploma what matters is
your college degree and then from that
point he goes look I'll pay for your GED
just take it you don't even need to
study you know how to do all this stuff
and I was intimidated cuz I was like
[__] if I get a g I'm not going to get
into a good college and he goes no no no
don't worry about it just crush it in
Junior College get the best grades and
then transfer to any college you want to
go to but then you joined another gang
and but it was a good gang the best game
seconds not far from the
truth
D I recently got my G uh GED recently at
what at 25 23 let's go baby what made
you want to get
it you just [__] got it
no no my wife she said you stupid go
down pretty much in the nicest way she
said hey Mane I think you should at
least get your GED and I was like why I
don't need that [__] she's like I think
you just need to get it she stared at me
the whole time I was like all right I'll
think about it then my mom's like yo you
need to get your GED if the Green Card
guys are going to look at you oh that's
right it looks better for it yeah they
don't want no dumbass in America and I
was like you're right so I went to get
my GD at 23 American Career don't you
need it anyways to become police officer
or no yeah yeah you do that's what it
was you know that's why I went
back at least you got it bro yo man damn
at least you got it it was the easiest
[__] though I'm not even going to lie
was it it is easy but at 23 I was scared
I was like damn bro I don't even know if
I know math cuz you haven't taken a test
in like [__] hell long I was scared
at 17 because I thought the GED was like
at the end of high school I'm like how
are you going to condense 4 years of
learning in one test right and then I
was like this is a joke like at the end
of all this schooling this is all you
need to know what was it like to just
basic math basic everything basic
algebra it's basic be a banker or join a
gang gang up to
you